The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: All right.
We're going to
talk about hosting.
I'm going to go through
rules quickly, guidelines
just the same as we did before.
Then I'm going to read a short
section of one of your scripts.
You're going to
critique my hosting.
And then we'll do the same
thing for some of you.
Again, we won't do everyone.
This we covered already.
Don't read it.
Tell it.
This is the Hourglass
video from before.
This is a subtle point.
You can start off by imitating
someone else's hosting style,
but you'll invariably just
get caught, as like that's
the only thing that you can do.
And since it's not
your own personality,
it's just sort of weird and
unnatural, and doesn't work.
I did this when I was
first starting out.
It did not end well.
These are my words
of wisdom to you.
And no more needs to
be said about that.
This is a really hard one.
So there's this device
called interview something.
I don't know.
There's a famous
director, who basically
has a silver mirror that he
puts in front of the camera.
And there's an image below.
It's like a teleprompter,
except, instead of text,
you see a person's face.
You see the interviewer's face.
So the interviewee is looking
straight into the camera lens,
but that person
is actually seeing
the face of the person
who's interviewing them.
So who's seen the
movie The Fog of War?
No one else?
OK.
You should watch it.
It's really interesting.
It's a documentary.
It's an interview movie.
And not Richard Nixon.
The Secretary of War for the
Vietnam War was McNamara.
So he was interviewed on that
movie using this technique.
And it's a really
interesting technique.
But the point is when you
look into the camera--
we don't have a fancy device
like that, unfortunately.
But when you look into a
camera, see a person's face,
preferably someone
that you know,
whether it's like a
friend, husband, wife, son,
daughter, whatever it is.
Pick someone, and see
their face on camera.
That is the quickest
and easiest way
to make your hosting more
natural without really
thinking about it.
And that's very hard
to do, because you're
thinking of your script.
You're thinking of
18,000 other things.
But that's the most
important rule.
Usually, the camera
tones you down.
So if you are talking like
you would normally talk,
you will kind of seem
like this on camera.
It just tones you down
and slows you down,
and lowers your energy level,
unless it's right in your face.
Then it's different.
But usually it's not
right in your face.
So you need to
compensate by-- I really
hesitate to say, up
your energy level,
because when people say that the
initial reaction is to be like,
and then, you need
to talk like this,
because that's how-- and that
just doesn't work either.
So you want to be a
more energetic version
of your natural self.
So think of if you were just
really excited about something,
how would you actually be?
That's how you
should be on camera.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And just
to have physical metrics,
higher energy doesn't mean
higher pitch and tone.
That's the biggest thing that
happens when they say, now,
with more energy.
Then people talk with a
higher tone, like this.
And that's the last thing
you want to do, generally.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
So now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to read this.
And you all are going to
critique my hosting style.
And I'm going to read
it as if-- I'm going
to deliver it as if-- oh, wait.
No, most of this is a quote.
So let me do something else.
I'll do this.
I'm going to deliver this
as though it's not my job.
OK.
Ready?
Here we go.
Why do some people handle
cold better than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside with all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer for a morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
OK.
Critique.
What was wrong with that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I felt like
you could do more.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: In what way?
AUDIENCE: So you were
restrained by the fact
that you were looking
at somebody else's work.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
That is true.
So if I was reading something
that I had written myself,
I'd probably do a better job.
But in this case-- you will
be reading your own work.
So that won't be quite the same.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I think
just how you read it,
it seemed like you
were asking a question,
but there's no, oh yeah,
I've never thought about it.
It's like, why do some people
handle cold better than others?
Maybe if you changed it
to like, have you ever
wondered why some
people-- and try to-- I
don't know if it's the
structure of sentence
or just how you said it.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And this
is part of the exercise,
as I'm reading it word for word.
So let's assume that I
can't change the wording.
I mean, in real life, you can.
But what could I do just
with intonation of my voice,
or what else?
AUDIENCE: Maybe slow
down a little bit,
and really hit
that question hard.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
You were going to-- no,
you had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: I'm going
to think a bit more.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: The intonation,
when you ask a question,
you probably want to
raise it at the end.
And if you were to ask
a very [INAUDIBLE],
because there are a
couple of questions there.
So I guess you can pick the
one that you really want them
to think and give them pause.
So get them to think
before you [INAUDIBLE].
ELIZABETH CHOE:
That's a good point,
that you can create suspension
in your tone of voice.
But a lot of people
make the mistake
of assuming that every question
has to end with an uptone.
Right?
A powerful question can be posed
with the tone ending downwards.
Why do some people handle
cold better than others?
That is still a
strong question even
though I didn't say, why
do some people handle
the cold better than others?
That actually is--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Well, you didn't
end upward on either of those.
The ending upward is like,
why do some people handle
cold better than others?
That's the traditional way
that people asks questions.
But I agree with you.
The way that I read it, all
the questions were flat.
All had the same intonation.
What I really want
to do is vary.
So something like,
why do some people
handle cold better than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear, all the
mask and all that stuff,
where other people can just
where one layer for a morning
jog?
What's the difference?
So each question I asked there
in a totally different way.
What else?
ELIZABETH CHOE: So a
big piece of advice
that we give to students
is to think about the words
that you're saying,
which is also the hardest
thing to do when you're
trying to remember everything
that you're saying.
You have a camera
in front of you.
But that's also why we
often take the script away
from the students.
It's easy to get
caught up in, oh shoot,
I have to remember
all the words.
And I'm very, very
guilty of this as well.
So I totally understand
how hard it is to do.
But when you are asking
the question genuinely,
why do some people get cold
while other people don't?
The way I said that was
very different than why
do some people handle
cold better than others?
When I'm actually thinking
about the words that I'm saying,
which is a very obvious
suggestion to make, but,
again, very hard to
implement yourself,
the intonation and
the delivery become
a lot more natural and genuine.
I don't know if you want
to add anything to that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah,
and that's another rule.
Like when you look into the
camera, see someone's face,
that's something that you
can do that doesn't-- I mean,
it requires some preparation.
But it doesn't require thought
while you're actually doing it.
So when you look in the
camera, see someone's face.
And actually think about
the words that you're saying
is helpful too.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You
want to avoid monotony
not just in the intonation.
So you don't want to say,
why do some people handle
cold better than the others?
Why is it that some
are so fearful-- right,
that's monotonous in tone, but
it's also monotonous in rhythm.
All right.
So when George said
it the second time,
he rushed through
some of the words
in the middle that were in a
list, which is very natural.
When we're like, this
morning I have to go to work,
and I have to do this, and
I have to do this, and this,
you rush through
things that you list.
Whereas, if you're just
reading like you would read,
you say it with the
same rhythmic pacing.
You make the pauses
where the punctuation is.
You sound very even with the
way you break up your words.
And that's super unnatural.
That's why it sounds robotic.
So when you mix up not only
the intonation, but also
the speed at which you're
delivering some of the words--
I don't know.
You can do it again
and maybe pay attention
to how he does it.
That's kind of also why it
feels a lot more natural.
So I'm going to do it again,
this time completely different,
and get your critique as well.
Why do some people handle
cold better than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they would rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear on, mask
and all, while others can
where one layer
for a morning jog?
What's the difference?
Was that better or worse
than the first time I did it?
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like a Ted Ed video.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It sounds
like a Ted Ed video?
Oh man, then I'm not making
very good Ted Ed videos.
AUDIENCE: Better than the first,
not as good as the second.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
Why?
What was inauthentic about that?
AUDIENCE: You sounded too
intentionally energized.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
So normally, when we say
to someone, up your energy,
or when anyone says that,
that's what comes out.
You get this weird,
I have to really try
to be excited about this,
because I don't really
know what I'm reading.
But I'm going to just
emphasize random words
and say them louder.
And that makes it exciting.
No, it doesn't make it.
And especially, if you mix that
in with a bit of newscastery,
then you're just
dead in the water,
because you end up with the
most unwatchable video ever.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And you
sound like you're trying
to talk to a 2-year-old too.
I think that's the final
effect, which we want to avoid.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
Now, I'm going to read it again.
And this is going to
be a bit more subtle.
Here we go.
Why do some people handle
cold better than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear
one layer and be fine?
What makes the difference?
What does that
sound like to you?
AUDIENCE: It sounds
more natural,
like you're talking to someone.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It definitely
sounds more natural.
Any critique of it?
AUDIENCE: I think it sounded a
little disinterested at parts.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Uh-huh.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It was kind of like
a little bit of a mumble,
like when I talk, and I'm
going on like this. [MUMBLING]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's
like, yeah, [MUMBLING].
It is very natural.
But there is a lack of wonder.
This is a topic that I am
sort of taking for granted.
And I sort of expect that
you'll take it for granted too,
so you do take it for granted.
All right.
I've sort of run out of
different ways to do that.
So let's have you guys try.
Who did not have
their script analyzed?
Come on up.
So take my hot seat there.
And give us a read.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer for a morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: One more time.
Differently.
Do it differently.
By the way, those of you that
will do production with me
and Elizabeth, that
is the phrase that you
will hear most throughout
the week is, one more time.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
Why is it that some people
are so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear on, mask
and all, while others can
where one layer
for a morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Do you have
the first sentence memorized?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Deliver it
without looking at the script.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Now,
look at Elizabeth,
and just ask that question.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Now, don't
have the line in your head.
Just ask her.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Now, ask me
as if I were Eric Lander.
AUDIENCE: I've never seen him.
Why do some people handle
the cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Elizabeth, sit closer.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK.
I'm a professor.
And you're at my office hours.
And I've given you
the piece at question
relating to hypothermia.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Now, ask the
question in your own words.
Don't use the words that
are written on the script.
Ask Elizabeth.
AUDIENCE: Why are some
people so immune to the cold?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So do people
see how hard this is?
This is really not easy.
Right?
Thanks.
You're good.
Come on back.
All right.
Who's next?
Your turn.
Same paragraph.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Why do some people handle
cold better than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer for a morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: One more time.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer for a morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Now, do the
first time without reading it.
AUDIENCE: I have
a horrible memory.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Don't
worry about the words.
You can say it however you want.
AUDIENCE: I guess, it's just--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What's
the video about?
What's the video about?
AUDIENCE: Dealing
with the cold weather.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Say who
is dealing with it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I have it.
Why are some people better at
dealing with cold than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
You can sit down.
Anyone else want to go?
Anyone else want
to give it a shot?
Yeah, come on up.
Same paragraph.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
Why is it that some people
are so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear
on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer in the morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: One more time.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle the cold better
than others?
Why is it that some are
so fearful of the cold
that they'd rather
die than be caught
outside without the winter
gear on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer in the morning jog?
What makes all the difference?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Great, thanks.
What time is it?
Do we have time?
ELIZABETH CHOE: You only
have like 10 minutes.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
What did you guys
notice about all
of those, all three deliveries?
Were they different or similar?
AUDIENCE: Both.
Their personalities
came through.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
But-- it sounds like
there was a but.
AUDIENCE: But they
had a really hard time
doing something different than
what they did the first time.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I don't
know why this is.
I don't have any
cognitive theory
as to why it's so hard to do
something so differently-- when
you have the same
words in front of you,
why it's very difficult to
read them in different ways.
But this just happens
with everyone.
And especially, if you've
written the script yourself,
you know the words
so well, you've
looked at it a million
times, when it comes time
to actually be on camera
and perform that script
and we say like, OK, well,
that was great, but do
it a different way.
You're like, well, I
wrote it this one way.
Why should I do it
a different way?
Maybe that's what your
brain is thinking.
And so you just don't know
how to do it a different way.
Let's try something a
little weird and creative.
Julia, right?
Do the first line,
but try and do
it as different from your first
reading as you possibly can.
And I mean, if you
want to exaggerate--
don't think of this
as I'm hosting a line.
Just think of it as I'm going
to say these words in the most
different way I can think of.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's OK if
it doesn't make any sense.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like, why do something
handle cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So valley girl.
OK, good.
That was very different
than your first delivery.
Great.
Remind me of your name again.
AUDIENCE: Joshua.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Joshua.
Go ahead.
Do the first line totally
different than the way you did
it, and not valley girl either.
AUDIENCE: Why do people
some-- OK, let me try again.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Why do people sometimes handle
cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
That was an accent.
So great, very different.
Remind me of your name again.
AUDIENCE: Nathan.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Nathan, your turn.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Julia, yell the line.
AUDIENCE: [YELLING]
Why do some people
handle cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK,
now, close your eyes.
And just say it.
Ask the question.
AUDIENCE: Why do some people
handle cold better than others?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, that
was your best delivery.
I don't know why.
Sometimes getting people to step
way outside their comfort zone
and do a line in a
totally ridiculous way
that you would
never actually use
resets something in
your mental circuitry.
I have no explanation
for why this works.
But you get out of your normal,
and then you just sort of do it
the way that you
would normally do it
if you were talking to someone.
That's a technique
that we'll also
use when we're in production.
We'll be like, OK-- actually,
we might even say, do
this line as a valley girl.
Do it with an accent.
Yell it out loud.
Do it like a robot.
[TALKING LIKE A ROBOT]
Why do some people
handle cold better than others?
And then do it in
your normal-- why
do some people handle
cold better than others?
I mean, that was
different than how
I've done it every single time.
What other hosting
tech-- I mean,
this is just one of those
things that practice--
you need to practice.
And you should do it,
like I was saying earlier,
with an audio recorder.
You have them doing vlogs.
Right?
ELIZABETH CHOE: Mhm.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It
might be good to change
one of those assignments
into an audio vlog versus a--
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah, actually,
for your daily reflections--
I know Siri did a video just to
make sure that you guys knew.
But you don't have to
do text reflections.
You can do an audio
recording if you want.
You can do a video
blog if you want.
And I think that's
a great opportunity
to practice some of this stuff.
Your reflection last
night, it was really good.
It was really authentic.
You weren't trying to host.
But I thought you did a
pretty good job on camera.
And it was very different
from your pitch.
Right?
I would suggest that you
go back and watch yourself
on both your pitch and
on your blog last night.
And you'll see a pretty
surprising difference.
And it happens to all of us.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: When
you listen to-- that's
the other part of
this is that once
you do your vlog, reflection,
or audio vlog, or whatever,
listen to it, and see
what you sound like.
Do one where you're just
talking off the cuff.
You're like, today was great.
We had this guy.
He was terrible.
But he had some good
points, whatever, whatever.
And then do one
where you actually
read-- you can read even this
same paragraph if you want,
or pick something
that you've written.
And listen to the difference.
I think it's only
by sort of really
listening to yourself that
you will learn to do this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Have you ever tried
to have people do practice
dry-runs, and maybe tell
them that it's not running--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yes, we
do that all the time.
We'll say, oh, this
is a rehearsal.
We're not rolling, but go ahead
and deliver the line anyway.
Sometimes it works.
It usually doesn't,
because you've still
got the camera there.
It's still--
ELIZABETH CHOE:
And the other thing
is even though we want you to
sound as natural as possible,
when it comes to
the day of shooting,
the more you've
practiced your lines,
it just takes out one more
confounding variable that
will stress you out
during the day of shoot.
The students, you can
really tell if they've
rehearsed their lines.
Even if we end up changing
a lot of the wording,
they're just much
more comfortable,
because they're not worrying
about remembering things.
They actually are thinking about
the words that they're saying.
For tonight's
assignment, it will just
be to recreate
your episode pitch.
I would suggest that
you redraft your script.
We are going to do a
table read next Monday.
And there's no
official assignment
for another draft of
a script until then.
If you want feedback on any
material that you write,
which I would recommend, I
am happy to give feedback.
George--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yep, I'm going
to write my email right now
ELIZABETH CHOE: --is happy
to give-- his email's also
on the syllabus.
We're all happy
to give feedback.
We will have traditional office
hours today, tomorrow, Friday.
So there's lots of
opportunity for feedback
before the table read.
But just so you guys
know for tonight,
it's just a repitching of
an idea for your episode.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: That's all
the material that I had.
Does anyone have any questions
in the two minutes remaining?
And I'm going to stick around.
So if you guys want to
chat with me individually,
that's fine too.
AUDIENCE: So basically,
to host, just be yourself.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
To the most extent that
you can, be yourself.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And I
mean there are exceptions
to every single rule.
I know that when I host,
I'm very different than I
am in real life.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Not really.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Really?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: No,
you're pretty similar.
ELIZABETH CHOE: You said
that my hosting persona
was a lot different
than you were expecting.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I was
just messing with you.
ELIZABETH CHOE: But for
the most part, be yourself.
And we mean that very literally.
Right?
I don't know if
you guys noticed,
but that time you asked that
question at the very end,
it was how you would say it,
and it was the best delivery.
It really was.
AUDIENCE: So less of like a
pitch to get people excited,
but just kind of explain
what you're doing?
Because a pitch, just
[INAUDIBLE] kind of
like excited.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well,
when you think of pitch,
you think of Shark Tank.
And you think of, I have 30
seconds to buy into my idea.
So I'm just going to be as loud
and exaggerated as possible.
So please don't
mistake pitch for that.
Keep it under a
minute and a half.
A lot of your videos were
five and a half minutes.
That's longer than your
entire episode is going to be.
Keep it under a
minute and a half.
Not just as a challenge,
but that'll really help
structure the way you deliver.
And that should be the
point of the video.
So maybe don't think about it
as a pitch as it is a point,
like a thesis almost.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Think of it
as explaining your video
to someone else.
AUDIENCE: So it's not the
actual stuff that you wrote?
ELIZABETH CHOE:
It's like a trailer.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Remember-- Paul, right?
Remember when Paul was
doing his shoebox thing.
It's that.
AUDIENCE: I don't think
I have a shoebox, but--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: You
can just mime one.
ELIZABETH CHOE: We've got a
budget for a cardboard box.
Let me tell you.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: We've
got about $1.50.
OK, thanks, guys.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right.
We'll stick around for a while
if you guys have questions.